hey youtubers is Charlie and because I
just passed 250,000 subscribers I wanted
to post a shiny new Doctor Who video a
lot of you been asking me for a new one
and whatever I started my channel it was
so that I could make a video for the
2012 Christmas special so why not
celebrate by making a new series a video
so this is gonna be a series 8 video
with a breakdown of all the new things
that are happening behind the scenes and
what kind of Doctor Who videos I'm gonna
be doing this summer but I wanted to
start by asking a really important
question how would you guys feel if
Steven Moffat and the Doctor Who team
changed everything about the show that
is from the way it looks visually to the
Canon rules from classic ooh judging by
a lot of the comments most of you guys
would either be you know one really
worried or two just absolutely hate the
idea the reason I ask is because Steven
Moffat has said that they're making the
biggest changes to the series since it
came back in 2005 since he tends to
exaggerate a lot here the top 5 things
that I think that that means number 5
they're gonna change the number of
companions the doctor has at any one
time we know that Clara is gonna be the
core companion for the series but Danny
pink
is jumping onboard the TARDIS ain't
after but the first couple of episodes
and there's rumors about another new
companion coming the rumor is is that
Ellis George is playing his sister Danny
pink sister and will also become a new
companion her character's name is
supposed to be Courtney you can see her
here in these pictures from the set that
show her wearing the same spacesuit from
the outdoor scenes on the beach since
2005 the doctor has really only had like
one or two companions with him at any
given time the current record holder for
a total number of companions though is
still David Tennant with eleven but he
would only travel with one or two of
them at any given time the Eighth Doctor
also had a brother and sister companion
team named Gemma and Samson Griffin he
met them in a library during the Terra
Firma audio drama before the 50th
anniversary a lot of the non TV stuff
wasn't really canon but Steven Moffat
changed all that I know a lot of you
guys were really happy when that
happened number 4 they're gonna change
how previous doctors can come back old
doctors coming back during a new
doctor's run is something they've done
in the specials but because of what
happened in the 50th anniversary it
seems like it's okay now for the doctor
to interact with previous versions of
himself you know with that the universe
collapsing on itself so Matt Smith is
supposedly going to interact with Peter
Capaldi via a phone call during series 8
we don't know
quite when that's going to happen but
Steven Moffat said that in the mummy on
the Orient Express episode the doctor is
going to be catching up on his phone
calls that's obviously a reference to
the handles phone call business from the
Christmas special before all this during
regular episodes whenever previous
doctors were featured it was either as
stock footage or other actors like in
the series 7 finale so now the other
doctor will be able to interact with at
least voice messages of other versions
of himself this series 8 phone call
isn't really a conversation it's just a
phone message but it is another new way
to feature previous doctors so everyone
really wanting classic doctors to come
back this is just another new backdoor I
know when you say you want classic
doctors to come back you're really
talking about visually on-screen though
Matt Smith even said after he wrapped
his last day he was bugging Steven
Moffat about how soon they could do
another anniversary special personally I
think it's gonna be about five years but
they could always celebrate a different
type of anniversary to get one out
sooner on to number three they're going
to be changing the doctors rules that is
the rules that he imposes on himself I'm
talking about the rules that he quotes
the official rules have changed a few
times over the years but with Capaldi it
sounds like they're changing them in a
really really big way so just as an
example here's a breakdown of all the
different versions of the first rule
that the doctor has had I think the
first time we heard it was during the
fourth doctor's run and it was do
exactly as I say that was during the
ribose operation in season 16 then the
seventh doctor's first rule was I'm in
charge which he said during Dragon Fire
in season 24 the ninth doctor's first
rule was don't wander off which he said
an empty child in series one they didn't
really change that between David Tennant
and Matt Smith both of them used that as
their first rule - but technically Matt
Smith developed an alternate first rule
the darker lies so don't be surprised if
Capaldi changes that first rule again -
number two they're going to radically
alter the doctors relationship with his
companion or companions plural each new
doctor changes the whole tone of the
show and the most visible way we see
that is in his relationship with his
companion or companions Matt Smith's
room was kind of like a relationship
comedy with you know universe ending
consequences like the Big Bang at the
end of series 5 it was Amy Rory and
River stuck in this awkward love
triangle based on the pictures we've
seen from the set it seems like Clara
and the doctor still have a
relatively friendly relationship at
least at the start of series a Steven
Moffat says some things that made me
think that they won't be totally best
buds by the end of the series at least
like Donna Noble and the Tenth Doctor
were they were like super buddies at the
end of each of their respective runs I
do think that the doctor and his
companions left on good terms though
whether or not they were best friends or
not giving Capaldi and Clara more tense
dynamic though it would be a huge
departure from a lot of previous
companion relationships that doesn't
mean he's gonna be a straight-up mean to
her or anything though but it is pretty
clear that they're subtracting the
romantic element from the doctor
companion relationship they're not
completely getting rid of you know
romance or comedy from the show though
and the number one thing that I think
they're going to be changing in series 8
the doctor is gonna be way less
dependable and he's gonna be a lot less
funny at least on purpose I think this
is the biggest change just because the
doctor has always been a caregiver as
the name implies a doctor is a healer
the war doctor even said physician heal
thyself when he regenerated at the end
of the fiftieth anniversary episode so
what does it mean when the doctor isn't
dependable or not as dependable as he's
been in the past whenever Steven Moffat
suggested this I just thought of Matt
Smith in a good man goes to war whenever
he saved Amy they had this whole montage
with Rory in the 12th cyber Legion and
there was no doubt in your mind that the
doctor would save her
it's like he's so invincible that he
unfurls the Headless monks robe and just
shouts at Amy to grab our coat so they
can casually leave making the doctor
less dependable means that Clara and any
other companions that come along are
gonna have to become a lot more
independent this could mean them flying
the TARDIS more or just bailing the
doctor out of situations rather than the
reverse the Christmas special even ended
with the doctor forgetting how to fly
the TARDIS I don't think that's gonna be
permanent but I do think that Clara is
gonna have to help him remember a lot of
things over the course of series 8 but
now it's your turn let me know in the
comments below what do you think the
biggest change is gonna be in series 8
so moving along here's an update on what
they've been filming Clara was just seen
wielding Matt Smith's sonic they've
completed filming a good portion of the
episode so I'd say this is from one of
the later stories this series the
interesting thing about that is is that
I can't remember the last time a
companion used a sonic aside from River
Song
they also just announced Rachel Talalay
will direct the final two episodes
before the Christmas special the
we'll be a two-parter we don't know a
lot about the story and we don't have
any information on the Christmas special
yet
so here's details on all the Doctor Who
videos that I'm gonna be working on
between now in the series 8 premiere for
the rest of this month
it'll just be regular production bonus
videos then in July I'll be doing some
special Comic Con related stuff just
because they'll probably bringing some
actual footage from series 8 and
dropping some new information then when
we get to August is really when things
start to get exciting I'm gonna be doing
a special countdown series that's just
gonna lead up to the series 8 premiere
it won't be like a new Doctor Who video
every day but it will just lead up to
the series 8 premiere I'm basically just
ramping up the number of Doctor Who
videos I do every week as we get closer
to series 8 so feel free to suggest any
bonus videos that you want to see they
can be about Series eight they can be
about classic ooh anything else Doctor
Who related
be sure to subscribe to get everything
and once we do get started with series
eight my episode videos will just be
like Game of Thrones it'll be like a
bonus video the episode review and then
like a Q&A video my next Doctor Who
video I'm working on is my top 10
companions that'll pry post next week
but right now click here for a breakdown
of everything we know about all the
series 8 episodes and click here to
learn about some of the new characters
that are coming thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives